are you worried for your own safety by
speaking out against
Putin do you know this is the question
I'm always asked every
time
but maybe one of you know someone who is
a fighter pilot do you actually ask them
every time are you afraid to fly that
plane
today or perhaps some of you know people
who work at huge
Heights
do you also ask them aren't you afraid
going out and climbing that height every
day of your
life and actually I was one of the
people who worked at Heights you know
assembling
things and sometimes I even uh forgot to
put the safety harness on
me and when you sudden you realize oh my
God there is no safety harness there you
start sweating
profusely and you start thinking perhaps
I chose the wrong
job nevertheless each of us does their
own job and you don't really think on a
daily basis how risky that job
is Martin I just want to come back to
the question about China it is
interesting uh president shei and
President Putin have signed a memorandum
of understanding they've very publicly
declared that they're going to make
their relationship stronger the
speculation or perhaps it's more than
that I'm not sure the president she sort
of first visit abroad for some time will
be to Kazakhstan to meet President Putin
um is is there is that an important
relationship going forward beyond the
sort of Economics that Mel was
describing it's always been a three-way
Dynamic haven't you you know you go back
to the days of Nixon and Kissinger and
China was always the sort of wild card
that was played in that cold war
scenario and I think China is very good
at exploiting that card um economically
it's a great opportunity for China
because Russia is losing clients in the
west so China sees an opportunity to
clean up economically but politically
China has a very clear opportunity to
become a world play a much more
important World Player than it already
is is um we'll have to see how it goes
between sh and Putin because there's a
lot of um rhetoric in these games which
is um you know is a little more than
rhetoric one more question online and
then I'll come back to you in the hall
CLA asks do you think Putin has
Ambitions to escalate the war in Ukraine
with countries in the
Balkans
I think had Ukraine not proved to be
such a tough nut to crack for Putin
Putin would now build plans to go beyond
Ukraine and build Soviet Union Beyond
Ukraine no
uh
and when the ukrainians tell us today
that they are fighting not just for
their freedom alone they are
right this is the
truth all right three more in the hall
okay there's I'm going to take a couple
over there and one at the back and if I
can get some more in if you're quick
then maybe we can get some more in go go
go through it um hi thank you very much
I just wanted to ask about and you
mentioned it the sort of brain drain
from Russia and what you thought of
policies now introduced by various
European States especially in the
baltics Banning Uh Russian student visas
do you think that that sort of policy is
what's needed to drain Putin's economy
or is it so harmful to the long-term
future of an open Russia um that you'd
be opposed to it okay and another one
there was chap front
yeah thank
you it was really interesting to hear um
your take on how Putin gets input um on
on different decisions he makes you were
talking about the economy for example um
and i' I'd love to hear your your review
on whether he sought any input before
invading Ukraine okay whether that was a
decision on his own all right there's
one right at the back over
there good evening I'm a Ukrainian
Refugee I live in London now I am here
because of the war and uh my question to
mik is uh how can you explain the very
huge percentage of support uh for Putin
from Russians Russian people please
don't speak about Moscow citizens and
diaspora thank you okay so three
questions there could The Brain Drain
actually be a way to weaken Russia to
bring Putin down um was the decision to
invade Ukraine Putin's alone and how do
you explain the Russian support for the
war in
Ukraine
uh the brain drain is really weakening
the
regime just one
example so Putin wanted to uh block the
YouTube in Russia but because of the
domestic reasons he needed to replace
YouTube with something else
he so they created the root YouTube
instead of the
YouTube so it had been developing for
some time and we were terrified to wait
for the moment when it was going to be
launched and then the 30,000 it experts
left Russia after the beginning of the
war and R just
collapsed have you noticed that they
speak less and less about Russian
hackers
today they have all left
Russia
uh the decision to invade Ukraine was it
Putin
so as for the decision to go into
Ukraine Putin really did think that they
were going to accept or to meet him with
open arms with
flowers mind you today his idea of
what's in Ukraine is much better but why
did he have that erroneous idea in the
first
place a simple
answer he was sitting in his bunker with
a very very small number of people he
would communicate
with one of these people was
whose father actually comes from nikol
in
Ukraine so Mr was perhaps not the author
necessarily of the um intervention in
Ukraine but at least a supporter of that
idea very much
sir and finally the last question about
the support for the war in
Russia well first of all I wouldn't
really believe all the opinion POS we
hear about and their results
a lot of sociologists have told me that
the results of a sociological survey
under dictatorship during a war are not
really a witness a testimony of
anything one of those sociologists are
actually present here yeah so you can
have a chat with them
later in a normal situation out of 10
people being surveyed two would give
answers would actually
respond and those two in fact represent
the opinion of the remaining eight more
or less
yes and now imagine that you are living
in a dictatorship and there is war going
on somebody approaches you in the street
and says are you pro war or against
it well one choice you have is just not
to
reply so the remaining two who do reply
what is this testimony
of they FSB agents that's
what but seriously speaking this
Nostalgia about for the Empire is having
you know a role in it
definitely this is why the people 55 and
older supported much more than people 30
and
younger and this gives us
hope interesting all right I'm going to
take two more and then we're out of time
afraid okay I'm going to go right to the
back there because I think you guys
haven't had a fair
shout just very quickly um Alexi naali
is he a good man and how come he's still
alive okay and there was one hand that
went up okay I'm going to go with this
guy there there's just a chat there yeah
little bit there you
go hi um what if anything uh gives you
hope okay so is Naval a good guy and
what brings you
hope
uh
naal today naali is a political prisoner
so I would support him irrespective of
whether our views and ideas coincide or
not
the only thing I would like to warn all
Russian citizens and people in the west
against is not to look for a kind Zar
there would never be a kind Zar in
Russia
uh so go tried to be this good Zar in
Russia how long did he last one year but
do you think Alexi naal wants to be a
good
Zar well the thing is that nobody wants
to to be a bad Zar everybody intends to
be a good one including Putin when he
started but isar as opposed to a
Democrat uh yes
I think if you want to see a free
liberal Democratic Russia which is not
an aggressive country it has to be a
parliamentary Republic and deeply
Federal so we're going to try a joke
it's difficult but we'll
try there is a factory in Russia which
makes really bad
cars so imagine a chief engineer and a
director of the talati factory standing
there looking
down looking over the
[Applause]
factory
they they're saying we've tried to
change all the equipment but it didn't
work we've tried to make to change the
models that we're making here in the
factory didn't
work what should we
do there the chief engineer says Ah this
is a godforsaken place this is I told
you
so the place of a in Russia it's God
forsaken it's
cursed even a good person sitting in
that chair sometime later becomes a bad
person interesting Martin do you have
any thoughts on that I I just wanted to
tell a an anecdote a joke um in Connect
with why many so many people in Russia
seem to support this Dreadful war in
Ukraine and how people think about what
they say about their attitudes and my
favorite joke is about the two FSB men
who at the end of a very long day are
having a drink in the FSB canteen in
Moscow and Dimitri says to Ivan he says
Ivan tell me what do you really think
about this Putin regime that we live
under and Ivan
says the same as you do
[Laughter]
and Dimitri says in that case it's my
duty to arrest
you we are really out of time but I am
going to ask you that's a wonderful kind
of end thought uh one that to answer
that last question which was what gives
you hope
m
well I've already answered this question
partly when I said that those under 30
do not remember the country we
remember
uh
Putin is going to die and my generation
is going to leave the stage as well
although I'm younger than Putin by 11
years uh
yeah uh when I spoke to people in
Germany I asked them when did people
forgo Nazism really in the end when did
they get rid of it in
themselves and they all spoke and said
as one man about
1968 it took a generation
change so this is my hope the new
generation